so i'm going to be talking about graphs
of sequences and i'm going to say graph
i'm sorry i've lived in the us for so
long i have to say graph now if you look
at something like the squares the
squares go 1 4 9 16 blah blah blah if
you make a graph of them this is a
discrete sequence they're separate
numbers and i and there's one start at
zero so zero the zeroth term is zero the
one term is one the two term is four the
third term is nine and so on so what we
get is something that looks like that if
we draw a continuous curve through it if
we plotted a thousand points the dots
would all merge together and we'd get
something that looks like that this is a
parabola single dots it looks like a
continuous curve parabola you did it in
high school boring boring boring
we're going to do more interesting
things i'm going to show you some that
you've never seen before but before i do
that here's another example the square
root of n
if we look at the square root of 0 it's
0 1 square root of 2 is 1.414
root 2
and of course they're not whole numbers
what i'm going to plot in this picture
is the nearest integer to the square
root of n it's not a continuous curve
anymore because i'm rounding it off to
the nearest integer so there are gaps
they're like clusters aren't they yeah
square root of 100 square root of 101
square root of 102 that's all gonna
round off to ten so we're gonna around a
hundred and they're all at ten so that's
another example of a pretty pedestrian
graph i want to show you some more
interesting sequences remember that
movie
called avatar the hero jake scully gets
on the banshee for the first time he
links to it and he tries to get the
banshee to fly and it doesn't work
here's a sequence that reminds me of
that
i call this
sequence fly straight damn it and the
definition is this we start off the
first two terms of one okay and now the
rule kicks in what is the rule this is n
and this is a of n now what's the next
term you look at the last term and then
and you compare them
are they relatively prime
in this case they are they don't have a
common factor and what it is it's the
previous term of n minus one plus n plus
one so in this case there's no common
factor so the next term would be one
plus two plus one which is four what
goes here well we look at three and four
do they have a common factor they do not
so again the next term is four plus
three plus one it's eight now we look at
this pair of terms what's the fourth
term we look at four and eight aha they
have a common factor of four when that
happens we divide the previous term by
that common factor
so here the common factor is four
eight divided by four is two
so
a of n the rule is it's either the
previous term plus n plus 1 if the
greatest common divisor of a of n minus
1 and n is equal to 1 if they were
relatively prime or
it's equal to a of n minus 1 over gcd of
n and a of n minus 1 if this gcd
is bigger than 1. so let me let me see
if i've understood it so there's no
common divisor there between 5 and two
so our next number is eight
okay now there is a common divisor there
is it two yes so eight divided by two
four yes
no common divisor so our next number is
12 yes common divisor there is four yes
so the next number is three yes
we have a common divisor again which is
three so it's one yes
now we've got
ten and one so twelve
there's no common divisor there is
there's like 12
no common divisor there so now we jump
up to 24 24 and so on when we look at
the graph of that it's just wild it is
totally random looking random array of
dots
until
we get to term 600 and something
and at that point
jake sully
says to the demon fly straight damn it
and from that point on
you remember in the movie the music is
chaotic the banshee is tumbling they're
falling to the bottom of the cliff
whatever it is but then suddenly the
music calms down and they fly smoothly
so what's happening is this situation
changes when we get to a of 2m
equals 1. here was a of nine we got a
one at the ninth step it's not until we
get to term number 600 and whatever it
is that we first get a one at an even
term and when that happens let me show
you what happens we'll have an even
numbered term which is a one so there's
n and there's a of n
now what's the next term well it's going
to be term number two n plus one and
what's its value there's no gcd here
it's one the next term is the sum of
this plus this plus one which is two m
plus three the next one it's two m plus
two the gcd is obviously one there's no
common factor there so again we add and
we get four m plus six term number two n
plus three ah two n plus three four n
plus six g c d is two n plus three we
divide two and plus three into that and
we get two good okay let's get the next
four terms so two m plus three the next
term is going to be 2n plus 4 the gcd of
2
and 2m plus 4 it's 2. so we get to
divide this 2 by 2. and we get a 1. okay
let's keep going and you'll see the
pattern right away
now we get 2m
plus
7
2m plus 6 term
again there's nothing so it's it's 4m
plus 6 plus 7 plus 1 and then 2m plus 7
what is the gcd bingo it's 2m plus 7. we
divide that into that and we get a 2.
and then we continue what we get is 1 2m
plus 11 4m plus this went up by eight it
goes up by eight again and a two and so
on what happened is we had four nice
numbers in a row which is what you see
here there are actually two numbers
together here and then that and that so
with these numbers are on three straight
lines so although i can't see they're
not all that's a double line that's two
one two one two one down there on that
line exactly yeah yes and these are just
those other numbers yes and what those
numbers are is we went from two 2m plus
3 to 2n plus 7 to 2n plus 11. we've
added four and we've increased the value
by four so it's slope one and this one
we've gone up by eight so it's slope two
so this is slope one and that's slope
two
so from then on the banshee
and jake sully fire flies smoothly
it seems so arbitrary that we didn't hit
that magic point until here like you
know it was it just
it wouldn't trigger it's the magic of
mathematics yes it's just
a strange fact
about numbers some more another graph
another amazing graph another amazing
graph
the next graph we look at the primes we
don't but we don't just plot the primes
we write the primes in base two
reverse them
and subtract so let me do it
the first prime is two which in binary
is one node and we reverse it and we get
naught one which is one and we subtract
and we get one so it's p minus reverse p
in binary all right next one is three
reverse it we get one one
one one from one one three minus three
is zero so the next term is zero five
101 101
zero seven
one one it'll get more interesting in a
minute zero next prime is eleven now in
binary that's one zero one one when we
reverse it we get one one zero one which
as you know is thirteen eleven minus
thirteen is minus two so the final term
that we spit out that's back in base ten
yes right and the next prime is thirteen
well that's just the other way around
what we just did 13 is one one zero one
reverse it we get 11 and so that gives
us two when we subtract the next one is
17 which is one zero zero
zero one and we reverse it it's the same
and we get zero
nineteen we get one zero zero one one
aha one one zero zero one twenty five so
it's minus six after nineteen what's the
next prime 23 when we reverse it we get
1 1 1 0 1
which is 29 so 23 minus 29
seems to be minus 6 again and so on
that's the sequence take the binary
representation of n subtract its
reversal and we get a number it may be
negative maybe zero or maybe positive
and what does the graph look like it is
amazing it's a series of parallelograms
so these are parallelograms aligned
along the x-axis the parallelogram ends
when we get to a prime which is just
under a power of two the next one is
bigger than the power of two and it
starts another parallelogram which
starts off going down because the ones
are weighted towards the bottom when we
reverse it the ones are grouped at the
top so we get negative numbers just
after a power of two and we get the
symmetry just as you observe because
quite often the reversal of a prime is
another prime it's not guaranteed but
anyway it looks like that really amazing
graph this is just a simple graph of a
sequence
i wouldn't have picked that one
that's amazing but beautiful who found
that
and i did all right i was going to say
what crazy person decided to graph that
yeah well i've been graphing many
sequences because it's easy to do all
you do is click graph and in fact we
have a keyword in the oeis for a
sequence which is worth looking at
and the key word is look
we have other keywords keywords like
core for a core sequence and less for a
sequence that we don't like means less
means we don't want any more sequences
like this one thank you and if you see
look
you can click it and it will bring you
up the graph immediately and another
four letter keyword they're all four
letters is here h-e-a-r which means
click it and it sounds good
when you listen to
it so neil if i submit a sequence to the
oeis and then you put it on there but i
see less written under it i know that
i've picked a bit of a dead yes yes okay
but you're lucky it didn't get rejected
right
this happens a lot and we it leads to no
end of arguments
people say but this sequence is just
like another sequence and you look at
the other sequence and it says less and
then you can say that
you should have looked at what less
means
well let's forget about less neil will
be back with more interesting graphs or
graphs in the next number file video
including one that reminds him of star
wars
if you don't already please consider
subscribing to numberphile and give that
notification bell a bash to make sure
you never miss an upload to sometimes
see videos before they even go public
you can support us on patreon where we
occasionally do little sneak previews
thanks for watching and see you again
soon
and that graph will eventually as it
expands out you plot every single
integer negative and positive yes yeah
they're all there it just keeps going
wisteria so now the sequence is you take
n you write it in base 10
and you subtract the product of the
non-zero digits
[Music]